Nikki Haley picking up the endorsement
of drum roll
please Paul Ryan do not discount the
Americans for Prosperity endorsement of
Nikki Haley two days ago that's actually
a really big deal and the reason that
that's a really big deal is you could
say that Ron Des Sis's big advantage
over Nikki Hy was his ground game in
Iowa which is impressive America's
Prosperity has an extremely impressive
ground game uh this is the coke networks
um ground game they just gave that to
Nikki Haley so not only does that her up
in Iowa with Rhonda sandz that get gives
her a ground game in all these other
states and the calendar plays to her
Advantage so I'm not saying I'm you know
all for Nikki Haley I'm for beating
Donald Trump I'm for any Republican who
can beat Donald Trump but I think if you
had to pick a growth stock I think Nikki
is the growth stock whether Nikki haly
likes it or not she is now the
establishment candidate for the GOP